i will be your host tonight jagman x
and this is the playstation 2 quiz night
with a secret bonus round
hell yeah very exciting
side there it is
not quite yet but we'll go through them
so
you're gonna have two tiers well sorry
three rounds the first round
is going to be round one
general knowledge and pixelated pictures
and this has a difficulty of easy so
hopefully
this will ease you in kind of jog your
memory because i know we're all about
the ps5s the xbox
one
[Music]
we're all about all those new gen
next-gen consoles
and now we've got to remember the ps2 so
let's go round one don't forget
write down your answer and then we'll go
through
the correct answers at the end i'm an
amazing host
i make even the simplest things really
complicated let's go
number one i'm gonna get rid of my
little head here
here we go number one
in which playstation 2 game um harry
potter game i must say
can you not explore hogwarts and i tell
you what
i've probably spoken about this before
because i'm very passionate about this
how can you have a harry potter game
where you cannot
explore hogwarts it just makes no sense
you're taking so much of what makes
harry potter harry potter
just out of the whole experience and it
ruined
the games for me if i'm honest
oh yeah and look at the graphics they're
amazing
snape is a snoop is a gorgeous man
we love snape
harry papoot so we have
and all of these are on ps2 by the way
so don't worry you don't need to um
i'm not going to trick you out it's not
that one of these aren't actually on the
ps2
these all came out for the ps2 some of
them on other consoles as well
um so a harry potter and the fluffy
philosopher's stone or if you're
american harry potter and the sorcerer's
stone
b harry potter and the chamber of
secrets
c harry potter and the prisoner of
azkaban
or d harry potter and the goblet of fire
which one can you not explore hogwarts
write down your answer now
it's so weird with no feedback i should
have like a little background music
while you're writing your answer i'm
going to find us some little background
music just that we're not
sitting in silence listening to me rant
on
and on and on
here we go let's use my music because
why the hell not
just
i just
[Music]
okay now you should have all written it
down
an answers so i'm going to number two
what country is resident evil 4
set in gotta move my bloody head again
here we go is it a the usa
is it b russia is it c
africa or is it d spain
yeah it's time to think about that one
i fun fact i like i literally couldn't
get past the first
i guess boss in this game could not do
it
i did play it on the wii though i don't
know if that made any difference but
i found it extremely um extremely
difficult
so i'm super excited for the remake so i
can actually play this game
i see people trying to like maybe
they're putting the real answers down in
the chat or maybe they're just trying to
um
put others off the off the course but i
see you guys
i see what you're doing there okay
and number three
which are i had so much fun looking for
pictures
of the eye toy this was so much fun
today
and it just brought back so many fun
memories of me playing the itoy is
hilarious but anyway
which ps2 game was not italy compatible
so which game could you not
use with the itoy it doesn't mean that
you had to use the i toy to play the
game
but you couldn't use
the i toy
was it oh so a's
well i mean it might be throwing you off
here maybe i toy play isn't actually an
italy game but is it a
i toy play is it b abs sims and city
is it c guitar hero or was it d
harry potter and the prisoner of azkaban
harry potter again
what is it what game can you not do
anything at all
with the i toy this was actually um
i i got a flashback of something and i
was like no way
but anyway i'm not gonna i shouldn't
talk too much but i'm
gonna give stuff away
there's some people here who said
they're just guessing
oh no i thought this this is i thought
these were easy questions i'm sorry guys
mommy is he too much a gamer for you
oh i thought this is easy oh damn
leonardo doesn't know what the eye toy
is the eye toy is like um
the old playstation camera but for ps2
and it was like that it had little games
and then you could just like
like put your hand over it's like the
connect you know the xbox connect
it's basically the connect just not very
good version
well hopefully who's um i think it was
ib or something so that they were they
were gonna rock this so hopefully they
knew
some of the questions sorry if i made it
too difficult guys
okay um and you guys didn't know it
existed
you were missing out in your childhood i
thought it was so much fun
anyway number four
what was the best selling game got a
donation what was this
thank you so much antoine unfortunately
i had
a polystation durant
what i had a polystation durant half of
my
childhood what does that mean i don't
know what that means
i'm sorry i wish i could give you an
actual response to that but i don't know
what that means a police station
oh do you mean you only had to play
station one
because that's fine there were some very
good games that came out on playstation
one i remember playing like a
buzz lightyear game where it was like a
buzz racing oh and all the rugrats games
fun very fun although the best rugrats
game was a detective one
on the pc but anyway what was the
best-selling game of all time on the
playstation 2
come on we can all guess this like you
got this guys
you got this i believe in you you've got
this even the ones who didn't play ps2
you have got this
is it a grand theft auto san andreas is
it b
final fantasy is it c metal gear 2 solid
snake
or is it d tekken chicken 5
you got this you do
gamers assemble
oh my gosh polystation is a copy of
playstation it's an actual thing
i don't know this see you guys teaching
me stuff too
stash playstation
i wonder if i can play like old
playstation music in the background
that would be cool i just don't want to
risk i'm getting copyright strikes
playstation
i think i should be able to sorry
that's that's me let's carry on for a
second
oh this was the oh these are the fun
bits
okay okay one second
and i'm gonna show you some fun stuff
but i
want to try and find
some playstation 2
videos
so
were you a 90s gamer
was fable on ps2 was it just like
xbox i don't even know
oh here we go let's just listen to the
sims
let me have a little listen
did you see my head it went so fast
right anyway
moving on now it's time to guess the
pixelated ps2
game cover very fun so
this one it's not multiple choice
you just have to write down what game
you think it is
i think this this one's quite fun it's
not too difficult
i didn't pixelate them too much not too
much
wait fable 2 wasn't on pc though oh
so that was console exclusive only i
guess
interesting
next one amy
if you're still there you got this
mario could be could be sonic actually
look i'm just giving it away now
uh mantas i've seen this but i just
can't place it
yeah i think pretty much everyone has
seen this
come on amy
and next one seven okay come on guys
you must know what this is you must know
i want to give you hints but i'm not
going to see
because i do think that this is this is
definitely iconic
this one here
playstation 2 don't forget
so it's quite a while ago i can give you
the genre
spoopy there you go amy's giving you
both hints
and the next one this
if you haven't played this which i
understand because i don't think
everyone has
it's gonna be like what the frick is
that but if you play this you'll be like
oh yeah easy peasy
there you go see it's like easy easy
easy easy because it's just such a
simple cover and it can't be anything
else than what it is
okay now we're on to
medium difficulty yep guys that was only
the easy
stuff round two and this is my special
because this is all games that are
special to me in my heart so um
let's do this number nine what is
not a gameplay mechanic in the ps2
game a dog's life and i tell you what
if you haven't played this magnificent
game you need to play it
it's so funny or maybe we'll just play
it together
maybe we'll play it together sometime on
a stream but it's ah
i had so much fun with this game it's oh
as a kid and the radio stations the
radio stations
i think that's kind of one of one of the
games that opened up my mind to like
narrative designing games
because the radio stations if you listen
to them it would
foreshadow the next town that you were
going to visit and they
just had so much character and energy to
them anyway um
so yeah which is not a gameplay mechanic
in this
so can you go into a black and white
first person dog vision
can you customize the dog's fair coat
color
can you throw poop around
or can you possess other dog breeds
so you can do all of these in the game
apart from one
what one do you think that is
that you cannot do in the game
what do you want about ib i never played
this on the channel no i didn't
that's five four aaron said he should
have revised
it's fine don't worry about it get
get that dust dusty crusty old ps2 out
the attic
or just ask your parents for it you know
i'm sure a lot of you are younger than
me
go ah this
is probably going to be quite a
difficult question um because it's very
it's just me because i played this game
when i was younger but
who developed this adorable game curie
mix
it wasn't very popular um in europe
anyway
it might have been in america um it was
known as the adventures of cookie and
cream in america
in europe and japan it was known as kiwi
curry mix
it was such an interesting concept
because you would have your controller
and um
each joystick would control
one of the bunnies and sometimes you had
to work together
but one joystick was inverted
so you'd have to always go backwards on
one and forwards on the other
um just for them both to like be
constantly going
up some sense because one of them was
inverted and the other one was not
inverted
oh and your brain had to just work two
different ways all the freaking time and
you're also on a time limit
it was an extremely hard extremely
stressful game and often i would just
play it with friends and we would share
the controller because that was so much
easier
but it um just so you have a little bit
of background on what the game was about
it looks cutesy
but trust me it's so freaking difficult
so um who develops this adorable game
was it a game freak was it b
sega games was it c from software
or was it d lucasarts
five five four three
two one
[Music]
eleven name this spooky game
it's one of my childhood favorites don't
ask me why i was playing this when i was
a kid
i think i just borrowed off a friend but
it was it was a good game
is it cold i'll move my face a little
bit so you can see it properly
is it called the reckoning the great
escape
alone in the dark or the suffering
i gave you a little tiny bit of it so
you've got a hint at least if you don't
know
what this game is
it just crossed the one away it's an
eight plus it's an eight plus i swear
the great escape yeah it's a great name
alone in the dark
five four three
two one
i need i need um i need to be like h3
and have someone here just doing like
all my sound effects and stuff so i
don't have to worry about that
ah that'd be so good 12. obviously you
had to include beyond
evil here so um what food dish does
paige
shout out throughout the game as you're
playing
is it a lasagna
is it b enchiladas
[Music]
is it c tacos
oh is it d chili garni
which one is it honestly he does shot
one of these out
it's the crazy
it's such a beautiful game it was made
so long and it still
just holds up so well i think
graphically
it's very aesthetic and twin got hungry
relatable five
four three two
one
round three ding ding this is
onion night special so it's it's
braden's questions he did these
and he didn't give you guys any multiple
choice so this is literally the hardest
round okay sorry about this
what yeah this is such a i wouldn't get
any of these right so literally don't
worry about it
if you can get these right you are the
mvp
um what year did gta 3 release
i've got some little pictures just for
like nostalgic value
but yeah i can't give you any any other
clues
oh it knows it knows it knows
people were like
[Music]
in that chat yeah it's difficult right
you you are on the right lines
around early 2000s yeah
tough tough tough one okay
give me five more seconds five four
three two one
next one in um
final fantasy is that five no it's four
i don't know
the numerix i'm so [ __ ] at it but uh
what was the name of ty titus's
father as if i know i don't
i haven't played final fantasy so i have
not a clue
who titus is but look he's in the water
and his name is tied us
they have really weird names in final
fantasy like what was it
clay or something
what who do who cloud
cloud that was a name
clay comes in our chat
gianni keanu reeves
oh this is him by the way here this is
the um
the father titus's father i'm guessing
this is titus
i don't actually know but that's the
daddy
i think i mean he wasn't what i was
expecting when i googled
titus's father i was like oh he looks
very
like young and strong and you know just
doesn't look like a dad but
there you go although what am i saying
dads can look like how are they one look
like i should stop judging
daddy titus
five more seconds five four
three two one
next oh okay click it fifteen
what for so this is if you like car
games and
actually funnily enough i think this
this the answer to this question is one
of the only need for speed games i've
played
but what need for speed game released
after need for speed
underground too
i think man has got this he's like
[Music]
oh don't worry leonardo i'm going to
keep this livestream up
even though it's been me just like
trying to figure out
how to get some sort of music to play
for most of it
ah
yeah i'm pretty sure i played this game
that's the answer to this because i
played i probably shouldn't talk about
it i'll talk about it when when i tell
you the answer
yes mantas definitely knows
very happy very excited good news
okay five four three
two one
sixteen splinter cell made its debut
on the ps2 how fancy to phrase it like
that
who voiced sam fisher
another game that i personally have not
played
but maybe you guys have so maybe you
guys will know this
it's a cool picture though
i'm not sure what that guy's doing this
hand he's like he's like pretending to
make a gun
like maybe i can um intimidate him with
my own gun my handgun pew pew
oh abe can't remember his name the guy
who voiced sam
fisher
fisher is going to slap the guy with his
own hand
oh is that what's happening there
fair enough fair enough
i know it was an old guy some canadian
dude
i must remember
why are you hitting yourself why are you
hitting yourself ah
[Music]
sibling rivalry that just reminds me of
and the guy had a beard but the name
doesn't roll
[Music]
no in trillion
okay five seconds five four
three two one
and this is your your bonus round
ooh and this bonus round isn't actually
about
um about ps2 games tall so
have fun it's just something that i
wanted to put in here
but speaking of ps2 games
drumroll please
welcome to the 1990s
put my face here which is um
emo central or the emo time the time
when i was an emo
kid um
so i thought i would share some emo
questions with you
actually it's because i already had
these prepared from an earlier like
work quiz that i did i just wanted to
share with you but yeah that's uh
that's pictures of me as an emo kid very
i was very cool
very cool
so question one bet you weren't
expecting this question to come up today
complete the lyrics for system of a
downs chop suey
wake up grab a brush and burn a little
makeup
is it i just got to fade away the shake
up
what'd you say when i begin to shake up
hide your feet and fade away the shake
up
i enjoy banana chocolate shake up
which one is it
i am quite proud of diapers gotta say
i enjoy banana chocolate shake up
the awkward time i'm just giving you
time and i just don't know what to say
you wanted to these are the lyrics that
everyone just goes
you want to do you wanted to
just wait for the chorus i don't think
you
trust amy's like yes yeah i told you amy
i told you like the bonus round
i want that to be d so bad i know i
enjoy putting on the chocolate shake up
so good
five seconds five four
three two one
[Music]
what did move me again what did the
lead singer in the rasmus
wear in their hair was it
an anarchy symbol was it
oh that was a or was it b a feather
or was it c a rose or was it d
a skull
what do you think it was
aaron's like i didn't advise for this
either
[Music]
sorry
oh no oh no amy's unknowing
before erasmus is like very old
very old you don't really hear it much
nowadays
it's been thrown it's like i didn't
realize there was gonna be
emo questions and like music and stuff
what is
this this is a ps2 quiz
no newness to us
five four three two
one
name these adorable emo illustrations
you'll only know this
if you were like badly into it
a willow and raven b
jack and sally c pawn and z
or d siren and zero
what were they called
my mom would know the answer how old are
you and trillian
i'm five five years old
and i sound like i'm 50 already
okay this is stumping a lot of people i
see so we're gonna move on
five just make a quick guess if you're
not too sure
four three two
one next question
okay there's one more after this so um
what band did tom delange form
after leaving blink 182 or is the
americans let's say
blink 182 really bad exam
excellent was it a 741
was it b fight star was it c
angels and airwaves or was it d made a
parade
uh don't waste your time on me
you're already a voice inside my
yet i miss you
in one direction and joins like one
direction
can you imagine not quite not
quite don't waste oh jesus
look at that top what the hell is
missing what happened
did you buy it like that what a waste of
material
sound like a grandma did you buy those
with rips in them
and the last question and this is
extremely obscure so don't worry about
this one
you can probably just make a guess for
this one is um
my head real tan i'm still here i'm just
small
um finish these lyrics from the song
emo kid by adam and andrew
i'll let you know kind of the beat i
guess so it's like
i'm an emo kid
stuff like that
um so is it
i'm an emo kid non-conforming as can be
or is it i'm an emo kid and darkness is
all i see
or is it i'm an emo kid i'm just a goth
wanna be or is it i'm an emo
kid my soul's as black as my coffee
and yes it is a parody song like taking
the piss out of you knows
sorry i made it more confusing that
probably made it easier than me just
singing them out
my soul is black as my coffee and that's
how i like my man
airplane 1980 reference didn't know that
didn't know that
i'm an email kid my soul's as black as
my coffee i'm an
emo kid i'm just a goth wannabe i'm an
emo
kid and darkness is all i see i'm an
email
kid and i'm conforming as can be
all of them go quite well i'm a
songwriter guys
didn't you know
all of the above it's only one i promise
you that i'm not i'm not giving you any
um
uh trick questions here
okay five seconds five four
three two one
and that's it that is it guys by the way
this
this image up here is uh by nikki
very talented
nikki gaurav
okay so now
we're gonna go back through your answers
and we're gonna see how many you got
right and then you can let me know and
when you see who the winner is
but i will keep this up so you guys can
do this again
uh or just in case you've come in right
now and you've missed it
you can always go back and watch it um
this has been really fun you
give this a thumbs up if you want more
quizzes i don't know maybe it was a
stupid idea but
i had fun just making all this for you
hey clay's here for your frame ps2 ooh
i didn't put fit your frame in this quiz
are we ready to go back through your
answers and see how many you got right
who's feeling positive i know it is i
think that might be about it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah getting all the
thumbs up you guys like quizzes that's
good
i really want to do one on mythical
creatures as well i think that would be
quite fun and horror obviously we need a
horror one
let's go okay hey vicious
buck vakiver
okay here we go the answer to number one
is
[Music]
you can already see it there's no point
it's uh harry potter and the goblet of
fire
the worst harry potter game
and they all went so far down
hill um apparently the fifth one wasn't
actually too bad but i didn't even
bother to play that because
the just the gobbet of fire just shook
my trust
just i just didn't have any trust or
belief in
in those games anymore um
it was a horrible horrible game
it was just um it was just action
action missions
one after the other and you had
objectives
multiple objectives that you needed to
find within each of the levels
and once you found one even though you
needed to find more
it would put you back to the beginning
of the level
i have to do it all over again to look
for the next one
and i get the logic kind of because
maybe you could have taken a different
path
but oh don't do that like at least give
us the option
but anyway it was just horrible because
there was no exploration there was no
learning spells
um there was no getting to know your
classmates or your teachers
it was literally just you in different
levels
just shooting things with you want it
might as well have just been like a
shooter it was a horrible game don't
ever play it
um all the other ones there amazing play
those
maybe not amazing now they were when i
first played them
i actually still really like prisoner of
azkaban anyway we're going to move on
now
let it all out for the frustration it's
just really annoying they had a
they had a system they they knew what to
do and
they were doing it so well and then
suddenly it just got to goblet of fire
and it was like what the hell are you
doing
what are you doing anyway number two
the correct answer was spain
it was actually set in spain
say game
and that will be the next next remake
right they're doing resident evil 4 so
there you go more you know set in spain
next answer is guitar hero and this
actually really took
took me by surprise because i remember
harry potter
being um compatible with the i toy
but i i can't remember abs apparently
you can take a picture of yourself
in herb sims in the city and then it
goes on billboards and then i just got
this flashback
of my face being in the game
when i played arabs and i was like i did
do that
and i would just make the most ugly
faces and then
i'd play arabs and my face will be off
there on billboards or like me and my
friends just like
just looking down at everyone it's so
disgusting
this is such a weird feature but it was
there
interesting but yeah guitar hero nothing
no
i-toy compatibility very surprising
um the next question four
if you got this then well done
uh yeah grand theft auto san andreas
you can see why lots to do first proper
open world game that i played anyway
i don't know about you guys um
why not buy it so
yeah knew it
everyone's like yeah we knew it new
next one is the pixelated photos
so hopefully these were like a little
bit more
um obvious but yeah you had spider-man 2
but if you put spider-man down you can
have it i'll let you have it
if you put spider-man down you got it
well done
proud of you got that spider-man
yeah i know right jamie it's so obvious
when they're side by side because i did
this
when i was doing the results i was like
did i need to pixelate them more because
it looks really obvious but no if you
don't really know what it is
and you haven't really seen the cover
before i don't think you'd know
so yeah spiderman is this one and then
six it's theme park worlds
theme park walls see
oh it all comes back now theme park
world
i hope you got that one amy
yes i think she got that one yay
i said rollercoaster typhoon oh you were
so close
you're so close i also i almost want to
give you that one
give yourself a half point jamie give
yourself a hand point you got the roller
coasters
yeah yeah if anyone put like roller
coaster tycoon you get half points
half points to everyone who put
protocols
number seven it's silent hill too
i saw you guys all like alien i was like
i can see why because of the colors but
no no no
it's sound hilton
that iconic game
i didn't pixelate this one very much
either
because uh it's it's quite simple and i
think it would have
taken away from it if i pixelated it
like over the top
oh no don't worry don't feel dumb
honestly it's
i can see why because the face also kind
of looks like it could be like an egg
or even the aliens you always like
curved
skull and the colors look spot-on
so i understand why you would have gone
for that
oh if you put sand hill you got that
just
i'm gonna i'm gonna be this is still the
easy round so if you put sand hill
you've got a point just like the
spider-man if you put spider-man not
spider-man 2 you got a point
everyone's like childhood trauma
[Music]
and this was valley so i had to pixelate
this one a lot because you could still
see the name
bully at the top but i figured if you
knew it
you knew it it could be nothing else if
you knew it
oh you know what i really want a second
game of this i heard rumors that they
were gonna make another bally
and then um it was gonna be based around
his parents um well like his upbringing
or his home life and why he was a bally
and look into the psychology of it
and uh i would have been so into that
but
i don't think it's happening
sweet we've got quite a few people that
got this one
nice okay i think we're moving on to the
medium difficulty now my ones the yagman
x
round so yes
what is not a gameplay mechanic in the
ps2
games uh game dog's life
and it was actually to customize the
fair coat color
which it seems the most tame of like all
of these options
but no you couldn't customize your
character you could get a different dog
like dog tag i guess collar
if you went to go and get your coat
cleaned
um but you couldn't change the color of
it
you couldn't change customize your
character
but you could poop fart and then you
could pick up your poop and you could
chuck it on people it's very fun
because that's all you want to do when
you're a kid and you get to play a dog
game
right
and number 10 the curing curie mix this
is the craziest thing it's so cute
but it was made by from software
but you can kind of understand it
because
um well from software
makes like stupidly hard games oh
and as i tried to tell you guys
this game is really hard it's quite
difficult
so yeah from software made a really cute
little game
about two bunnies
exactly the blood-borne prequel they
made this and then they were like you
know what there's just something not
right about
the game that we're making maybe there's
too much color
and cuteness maybe we need more
darkness and epicness but let's um
keep the difficulty no let's make it
more difficult
yes that sounds good and that's how our
bloodborne was
was uh born
let's make it better exactly
exactly mantas it's really funny though
okay next one name this spooky game one
of my childhood favorites
and it was called the suffering i put
the great escape in there because i
would totally
see why you guys would think it was the
great escape because
he's in prison and he looks like he's
trying to escape so
and alone in the dark is a horror game
and another horror game that i really
enjoyed when i was younger it sounds
very much like resident evil when it
boots up it's like alone
in the dark but this is not that
this is the suffering and it's the tale
of a man
who wakes up in um jail and he doesn't
know how he got there
but weird things are happening monsters
are appearing everywhere and you have an
insanity meter and when it goes up to
the top
you you yourself get to become a monster
and jesus you just like
maul everything in your path but it's so
interesting it's very silent hill-esque
in the sense that every monster that you
come across
um makes sense in the world and has a
has a background like a lot of them are
in um what they call
like straight jackets and stuff
like that and they move they move in
specific ways because they're they're in
so the straight jacket ones for instance
they can go if i remember rightly
they can tunnel under the floor and then
come up and they had the chains still
so the chains just like whip around them
that was so cool
but also it's all about like the trauma
from
from the jail cells just really
interesting stuff
anyway
12. it was chillicon connie
i think a lot of you got this one
yeah and then um if you have watched the
beyond good and evil 2
trailer he's making chili con carne
in that as well so a little nice little
throwback to the first game
where he just when you're fighting with
him he'll just run around and be like
gilligan
and you're like okay cool paige whatever
we'll eat when we get back home
let's just finish this mission now
and next answer
oh we're on the hard ones now we're on
the hard ones guys so if you got
any of these at all feel proud of
yourselves i'm proud of you
i would not be able to get these right
they're so freaking difficult
2001 is the year that gta 3
released who got that let me see let me
see in the chat who got that
and you guys were very around it i saw
like a 2000 i thought i saw a 2004 i
think
um ah jamie put 2002
so close but mantas got it that's great
nikki got it awesome nikki awesome
oh aim for 2002 she's so close you guys
are so close and this is so hard so
ah no
okay second of this round
he was called i don't know how to say
this
jet jet
jet yes
that's name is what he was called tide's
father jet
jet and tide jet
tide or water themed is it
it just sounds anyway
and i was like i'm so convinced that's
the prince of prayer i can definitely
see
definitely see how you got that he's got
like an interesting like
armor set up because if i move my head
you'll see
the armor's only on one arm i don't
really understand like where's the rest
of your
clothes you know just like
look at my boobies but i gotta keep this
one arm protected it's
it's my favorite arm it's my favorite
one guys
anyway
15. what need for speed game released
after nepal speed and underground 2 and
it was never speed
most wanted and i'm pretty sure i played
this one
i'm not was this the one and maybe you
could do this with more than just one
but i only played one but
was this the one where you could like
customize your car you just go around
the streets and then you have like
street racing and stuff
because i used to i had the coolest hot
pink uh car don't ask me like mate
make or model or anything i don't know i
just knew there was like
pink it was fast i had a big exhaust and
i had stickers
and i was happy with it
and 16
i said never speed three that counts no
that doesn't count
that doesn't count this is the hard
round i'm not gonna let you off on this
one
16 is splinter cell made its debut on
the ps2
who voiced sam fisher and it was michael
ironside
and i'm pretty sure i saw jamie say
something about ironside
just as i went on to the next question
so i hope that
hope jamie got this right i think it was
jamie that said it
apparently entry and says that kids
still play i'm guessing you're talking
about
uh need to speed in the ict lab during
lessons
i remember being in school and spending
my lunch times in the it rooms
playing playing on the computers uh on
websites you're not supposed to be on
and then your mouth starts to move and
you're like no
they swap ironside from eric johnson
huh
okay 17. this is the the
random weird emo questions
but this one was actually
hide the scars to fade away the shake-up
none of this makes sense like looking at
the lyrics
it doesn't make sense wake up grab a
brush and put a little makeup
on no just put a little makeup
full stop hide the scars to fade away
the shake up
that makes a little bit more sense i
guess but i think
what makes the most sense is uh i enjoy
banana chocolate shake up i think that
makes the most sense
maybe i should write um write some of
the down songs
i'll get in touch
next one if i move my little heads
it was a feather
the lead singer of rasmus wears a
crow's feather or is it raven's feather
raven's feather in
his hair
right a parody of chopsticks
i ain't dropping down a chocolate shake
up just like write about my favorite
fast food places or something
i knew he was a better guy yeah you got
it right
just a bad hair day what do you do to
cover up bad hair days
you just look for feathers on the ground
easy peasy
next one is pawn and z did anyone get
this right
did anyone get pawn and z if so i'm very
impressed
um maybe we should both be ashamed of
ourselves a little bit
but it's fine
it was a time in our lives and we can
now forget it
amy got it whoa you guessed it didn't
you
and jamie jamie guessed it too i think
it's because oh i guess
yeah so jack and sally everyone knows
well most people know that's like
nightmare before christmas
and uh simon and zero so zero actually
is from nightmare for christmas as well
siren i just put that in there because i
thought it sounded like
an emo name and then willow and raven
just sound like em emo names
so just put them in there
new nikki got them wrong new
it's okay what band is tom's lounge farm
after
leaving blink 182 it was angels and
airwaves and i actually really liked
their
first song everything's magic everything
everything's magic just sit back and
hold on but hold on tight
prepare for the best and the best is
right
we judge your hand and i'll make you
mine
everything everything's magic
what is an emo emotional i guess
they're kind of like emotional
emotionals
emotional emotionals just very emotional
all the time and emotional
copy my strikes no
no please don't
and the last one the last one and then
we can see who won
this is finish these notes from the song
emo kid by adam and andrew and actually
it was probably the most
boring sentence i'm in emo kid
non-conforming as can be you'd be
non-conforming too if you look just like
me i paint on my nails and make up on my
face i'm almost emo enough to start
shaving my legs
but yeah
i think it's really boring like it's i
like i like the other the rest of my
sentences
i'm an emo kid i'm a guy i'm just a goth
wannabe but they basically say that
throughout the whole song anyway so
that's probably a bit too
black and white i mean email kid muscles
as back as my copy
and there we go there we have it is
there another slide
that's just it thanks for joining
playstation 2 quiz night
thank you for joining
so the full um
the phone the most points you could get
on that quiz
was 21. what did you get
if you're watching this after the life
has ended please put it in the comments
down below i'd love to see what everyone
got in this quiz and also make sure to
like this video and tell me if you want
to do more
quiz nights for you i had a lot of fun
with this
and i i want to do like horror ones or
i don't know maybe uh
xbox 360.
mythical creatures definitely
that ps2 menu screen yes yes yes yes
okay so how many did you get and tween
got
oh jamie got 10.5 okay that's not so bad
that's like nearly half
um and twenty got three
i didn't reach the test
it's okay you took part and that's all
that matters
um mantas got nine that's not bad either
six and trillion aaron got seven with
upside down smileys
this is good though because i know i
should probably just make them make them
a little bit easier next time
it got 11 that's not bad at all
it's not bad at all it's it's in the
lead at the moment
at 11.
oh ashley edwards got 11.4
oh and amy got 11 too proud of you amy
you said that you weren't going to do
very well
and she was like yeah my emo side helped
out
see just throwing a little curve ball at
the end there just
you know you never know what you're
gonna get with the yag my next quiz even
though you've never done one before
let's do a ps3 quiz i i can't do that
because i never i never had a ps3
i went from playstation 1 to playstation
2 to xbox 360 to ps4
i can do no probably not it'll see i can
do a
game boy quiz but i didn't really play
that many game boy games
it's like an a-levels exam it's okay
this doesn't uh determine your future or
anything
i got one but joined halfway so i missed
a couple of questions ah that's
fine that's fine fritz okay so i think
our winner
is um 11 11.5 ashley edwards well done
ashley if if no one else is gonna
say they had anything else higher than
that
and twine says that ashley searched on
google
and twins calling you out actually what
are you going to say about it are we
going to stop fight here
were you searching on google i i believe
you're telling the truth
i believe you're telling the truth 52
mate
well congratulations
ashley
very well done um i did say that i would
sing a song
in your name ooh drama
cheetahs cheetahs if i
if i don't when it's rigged it's
leagued sorry i'll shut up
no no no no no don't worry we're joking
ashley we we believe you
we believe you
there you go see antoine says just
joking
good job ashley good job ashley ashley
is the winner
if we do do more quiz i'm gonna have if
we do any more quiz if we do do more
quizzes i'm gonna have to have like a
winning board
and i can have people's names on it and
then i can like
you know see if one person
always stays up in the top five or
something that'll be really fun
clay claims that they got 13. you're too
late clay i don't know if i believe you
because you write random stuff in the
chat all the time
amy's laughing
oh and trillian said that the teacher
accused you of cheating in the fifth
grade so i sat in the corner that's so
sad
don't mind we're not gonna accuse you
here we're not cute we're not accusing
anyone
but did clay actually win or was it
ashley i'm very confused now
oh no this was bound to happen wasn't it
i think it's ashley mantas just said now
he's saying 16. it's ashley ashley don't
worry
you haven't lost your crown clay is just
trolling
mata's like he got 22 at 21.
he was like he's passionate with 16.
there's no way anyone can get 16 on this
quiz
clay got clay up clay wasn't clay clay
you've got clay up clay very proud of
you clay
oh no way clay no way clay
go away clay no wait no don't come stay
stay
no shut up right okay ah
i've got to sing ashley a song
should i sing what should i sing i
always just want to sing the same songs
because they're like fan i think i'll
just do it anyway i think i'll just sing
and tate in love because it's fun
oh we got dressed up for you guys i got
this dress and i like have nowhere to
wear it because you know covered
so i thought i'd wear it now it's so
long
clay is slowly getting more points even
though we're not doing the quiz anymore
okay staff
[Music]
okay we're gonna sing to love it's gonna
be very upbeat and happy and this is for
ashley for winning the quiz the first
ever quiz that we have very proud of you
sometimes i feel
[Music]
love for
[Music]
once i
[Music]
take my tears
[Music]
you need someone to hold you
[Music]
now i
[Music]
take my tears
[Music]
me snow so i'm gonna pack my things
[Music]
anyways well done
well done so proud